quand nous avons un ministre et des
ministres à secrétaire des dernières
ministres qui sont complètement dépassés
par la situation et des directeurs qui
vivent la réalité de terrain dans des
bureaux des syndicats majoritaires qui
propose des solutions de salon
finalement c'est les gens qui sont sur
le terrain qui peuvent apporter les
réelles solutions mais ça leur fait mal
en fait la star fait mal qu'on ait
raison dans l'est de la france donc l
épicentre de l'épidémie en france
les collègues d'autres syndicats qui ont
distribué des masques dans leur brigade
valeur brigades sont toujours debout à
100%
voilà ils ont été contre leur hiérarchie
en disant aux collègues porter des
masques protéger votre santé
d'autant plus que vous pouvez ramener le
virus chez vous et eux un vecteur de
propagation auprès de la population
donc c'est contre-productif et quand on
compare les photos de policiers de tous
les pays du monde qui sont touchés par
le coronavirus nous sommes les seuls
mais cela peut pas porter de masque à
penser à passer pour des clowns dans le
monde entier
[Musique]
on l'accueille avec plaisir déjà parce
que c'est nos délégués coresponsable de
la santé pour les policiers qui a fait
la demande il ya maintenant plus d'une
semaine auprès de toutes les directions
dont la direction de la médecine de
prévention est la seule réponse que nous
avons eue c'est la médecine de
prévention qui a autorisé le port des
masques lavables il faut savoir que nous
avions également réussi à retrouver des
entreprises qui pouvaient nous fournir
des masques des usagers des gens qui
soutiennent la police ont fabriqué des
masques pour la police mais nous avions
l'interdiction administrative de les
porter et en fait ce ne sera pas
forcément l'idéal ces masques là mais ce
sera toujours mieux que rien pour nous
protéger donc enfin ça bouge un petit
peu même les politiques de différentes
villes sont 30 adapter ces mesures
donc une fois de plus nous sommes à la
ramasse dans la police nationale
ha l'employeur qui est complètement à
contre-courant des skis préconisée par
les spécialistes
alors par le système d oui parce que le
masque la vague donc a été c'est un
protocole qui a été validé par le chu de
grenoble que nous avons repris ensuite
le chu de strasbourg et la médecine de
prévention combien précisé que ces
masses que là n'était pas adapté pour
toutes les missions dans certains cas il
fallait vraiment des masses que je suis
un des masques ffp2 ou chirurgicaux
après comme on en a pas pour le moment
de toute façon ce sera mieux que rien et
là bas parce que l'on avait également
fait un recours au niveau de l'ue
conseil d'état a référé pour demander
l'arrêt de la destruction des masques en
france parce qu'on pourrait être
conditionnée une partie des masques
quant aux pénuries toutes les méthodes
sont bonnes pour permettre aux gens de
travailler en sécurité et éviter la
propagation du virus
[Musique]